and mr cranston is here
looking like hemingway oh
hemingway
is that a role or is that a new look
there's a role inside i can tuck all
kinds of food
for snacks later on no are you doing it
for a role yes i am okay doing it it
looks great but enough about the beard
let's talk about this role the movie is
absolutely delightful yeah you guys are
true
together i had such a great time
watching it usually i say why did you
like the role but i think the role you
liked it because it's just makes you
smile right well that's tony coming out
of covid this was the first movie that
i've done and i felt the restriction of
movement and freedom and the lack of
community that we were all experiencing
and i thought
i just want to do something fun and
light and
a story that makes you feel good yeah
and you got to meet the real life jerry
in preparing for the role what was that
what are they like yes they're great uh
annette benning and i flew
to michigan in the heart of michigan a
little town called everett one stoplight
1900 people and there we met the real
jerry and marge who are wonderful people
and uh real salt of the earth real
grounded they won 27 million dollars for
their whole consortium they bought a
truck i think that's the the biggest
expense and they set up it's a used
truck too i right yeah well you don't
want to explode so crazy
uh you would probably buy a new truck
wouldn't you yes i would yeah
and they set up their their
grandchildren with college funds and
things like that but that's about it did
you even play the lottery yourself
before this
you know off
you know just on a lark it's a certain
yeah but but did you really feel
sitting in covet i really want to do
something that makes people smile it's
like a vacation for the brain but it's
also a really good story
it is a really good story it it is an
underdog story um because who would
think you could count the lottery i mean
that you could that there was a wait a
little a loophole
that never that doesn't exist now there
was a flaw in the mathematics that jerry
selby who is has this
brilliant mathematical mind found and he
couldn't believe he found it
and he there
so he realized that if you play a
certain amount of money to offset luck
that the odds are actually in your favor
to win in this specific game called
windfall yeah we saw you last night at
the tonys and yeah you know what it's
like to be at being a tony play
does it make you think i want to come
back and do this oh yeah it did i love
it i wondered about that and it was such
a great show it was it was arianna
dubose i mean she was incredible crush
me yeah no that's insane i said her
phone is ringing off the hook today
brian people oh yeah i work with you
all right so gail mentioned picking a
role that makes you happy something else
that makes people happy a good drink um
i want to talk about though sombra hello
uh with co-founders
aaron paul so you said you want to make
this the number one best gal in the
world yes all right tell us a little bit
about the brand
dos hombres uh was a
a child of uh aaron and i
uh wanting to see each other after three
three years had gone by the end of
breaking bad and and we
this is how stupid men are
[Laughter]
women are so much smarter when they miss
someone they see them right men go oh we
have to play golf or we have to figure
out a business together in order to
justify
seeing each other and so we created dos
umbres so we can see each other and now
it's going through the roof wow with
less than a minute to go i love that you
and aaron have formed such a great
friendship from breaking bad you guys
are really tight yeah it's nice to see
it's uh i am the the god uh father to
his new baby boy and i couldn't be
happier it's it's getting my grandfather
fixed really nicely it's like i love it
you look fantastic i really want to see
what this next film is you look like the
most interesting man in the world can
you say what it is or no
it's i'm i'm doing the second season of
a showtime show called your honor oh i
love that show yeah it's gonna be a
little different okay oh look forward to
it thank you but meantime brian cranston
should check out brian in jerry and
marge go large it premieres this friday
june 17th exclusively on paramount plus